et on restait la frontière côté polonais
on retrouve magdalena shove nick bonjour
magdalena est ce que les ukrainiens
continuent d'affluer ce soir
oui bonjour je suis toute la journée
juste à côté de la guerre où il ya deux
il ya des trains de d'ukraine qu'ils
arrivent il y avait déjà du train qui
sont arrivés aujourd'hui mais il ya
beaucoup de délais parce que le train
sont arrêtés deux côté ukrainien pouvoir
en fait si les hommes entre 18 et 60 ans
ne quitte pas le pays c'est le rec en
fait qui est qui vient avec le lois
merci à qui qui a imposé en ukraine ils
doivent rester en ukraine pour protéger
le pays donc aujourd'hui on voit
beaucoup plus de femmes des enfants qui
arrivent en plein de ce côté et
continueront à à arriver magdalena on
voit qu'il ya une vraie solidarité qui
s'est créée autour de ces réfugiés
oui même ici sur le point d'accueil pour
les réfugiés
craignant il ya beaucoup de volontaires
de bénévoles qui sont arrivés pour les
aider il ya beaucoup de gens de chez
mais je suis en ce moment qu'ils ont
ouvert leurs portes en fait pour
accueillir les ukraniens pour ce qui ne
dure pas à la guerre ici il ya beaucoup
de polonais qui vient même en ukraine
pour aller le chercher pour les aider à
traverser la frontière
donc la pologne entière fait tout ce qui
peut en fait pour aider nos voisins à
côté qui ont été
agressivement attaqué pearl à rossi
justement comment est ce qu'on vit la
situation en pologne est ce qu'il ya une
vraie crainte que cette guerre déborde
en ce moment on sait pas vraiment ce
qu'on peut vraiment attend de la part de
poutine
donc les polonais j'ai l'impression
qu'ils se concentrent plus pour fait sur
l'action sur pour aider les épargnants
en ce moment mais il ya toujours une
pause cette crainte peut-être que
poutine va aller beaucoup plus loin que
le crâne est que ça peut arriver
vraiment à nos peurs en même temps
aujourd'hui juste des réfugiés et
beaucoup de réfugiés qu'ils arrivent
mais il ya des polonais qu'ils disent
même ici de volontaires ils disent
peut-être un jour ça va arriver à nous
aussi merci beaucoup magdalena